honestly it was not fair for me to drag
my own what was going on internally into
my world and putting it on them it's a
huge regret i should have never said
that i want nothing but the best for you
i have nothing but love for you okay i
don't want to see you hurt i care about
you and i don't want to put that you put
you guys in your guys's relationship and
that like now you give you give the
quotes
what's going on here
nothing
you good shayna i'm good i'm good how
has uh life been since the episode
started airing life is honestly it's
been good overall definitely there's
been some challenges but i've overcome
it i mean what was your reaction it's
broadly you're watching yourself back on
the show
it's
bittersweet there's definitely were some
moments that i was like
that's not what fully happened you know
again it's reality tv and there's
thousands of hours being filmed and
unfortunately the viewers are only
seeing so much of it
um but it's definitely it's been
interesting
do you feel like you were
fairly portrayed you feel like it was a
fair and accurate representation i think
things were definitely taken out of
contact with against anybody behind the
scenes i think people
opinions were already made by the time
it got to the beach bonfire scene that
was with shane i wasn't there to break
them up and i was very clear about that
um it was more of clearing the air of
what was going on behind the scenes that
wasn't on film but let's talk about you
and kyle for a minute
obviously you know you guys got engaged
to each other on the show he gave you
his mom's ring but you had a big
difference you guys have different
religious beliefs you shouldn't have
never said yes to me seriously you're
100 right and you know what it just
feels like you've been lying to me the
whole time i was not lying to you a part
of me was just conflicted the whole time
you messed with me i'm not mess with you
i swear
don't make me out to look like that i'm
not
oh my god
so sorry i feel sick right now why you
at me wearing your mother's engagement
ring when i don't want to be a fraud at
the end of the day
do you feel like
kyle didn't understand how important
your faith was to you yeah so
unfortunately
there was a lot being filmed of me
constantly reiterating like this isn't
gonna work this isn't gonna work
and
i felt like how many times can i tell
you and i can't i'm not gonna i'm not
holding anything to his head to stay and
he had that choice i didn't find out
that he was uh atheist until right
before he had proposed and again like
feelings were already developed at that
point
and so my internal conflict was okay i
had been engaged to a christian man look
what happened so it doesn't matter like
maybe he could be a good person and
maybe we can overcome it and at the end
of the day again this is an experi an
experiment this isn't real life this is
all within three weeks right this isn't
normal situations right circumstances
and so he knew the whole entire time how
i was feeling did part of you think
i don't know maybe it's possible it's
possible that we could grow beyond that
let's see what happens
a hundred percent i was like trying to
be open-minded the thing is i can't just
put it on
basic religious that's the biggest deal
breaker at the end of the day it was for
me i have nothing to lose here like i
had nothing but feel like i care about
you
you were like my number one well you
never told me that everyone will back me
off on that i don't know i don't know
i'm sorry why are you smiling because
it's just
i'm shy
you are so far so shy
why did you not tell shane earlier in
this experiment that he was your number
one
what happened was
during the pods um natalie's and shane's
their connection was very apparent right
away
and me and natalie were friends and so
it was just like an awkward position to
be and i was kind of like holding it
back per se
um
i definitely should have been more
forthright and i own that that was
another regret of mine
that scene with me telling me that
telling him that he was my number one it
wasn't to be like i was number one like
you should have picked me it was more of
me calling
um
the situation out that was not
filmed
unfortunately it does seem like you're
going to go to this beach party to get
him back
no yeah i know unfortunately yes and
that's that's what the viewers are
saying me and natalie were talking
i heard that like some things were going
on and i was like well if it doesn't
work out i have a guide for you i was
trying to be honest like i did say that
and again it is filmed that i'm like i'm
not here to break you guys up you know
what i'm saying and so unfortunately it
does look like that we all want to know
what to talk about what do you guys what
do they talk about
i want to know yeah what do they talk
about
i was asking and she was
staring at him like she was gonna cut
his throat if he actually told me really
yeah they're coming up they're holding
hands they're so [ __ ]
so it seems like you're kind of
questioning like what do they have in
common but what was going through your
mind in that in that conversation so i
actually called natalie um we talked and
i apologize for saying anything about
the relationship that was not my place i
was taking information again weeks prior
to before they even developed deeper
into their relationship and that was
very petty for me to say that and i
definitely apologize i should have never
questioned the relationship i feel like
i'm being portrayed as a certain like
villain under your relationship your
eyes is fake-ass relationship no offense
because it is a fake-ass relationship
you think it's fake it is such a joke
i'm sorry to hurt your feelings but i'm
again like i'm just being real why would
you think that
what gave you the impression that that
was
not a real relationship i guess it's
because i had like
again i don't want to throw anybody
under the bus but it went back to the
pods of just like seeing like again in
my third party retrospective like what
what compatibility did they have there
were some things behind scenes that like
people would say like oh it's rehearsed
like that kind of thing and so
i took that and
again
out of emotion of what was other things
that were going on it kind of imploded
as you can tell honestly it was not fair
for me to drag my own what was going on
internally into my world and putting it
on them it's a huge regret i should have
never said that and i've apologized and
i wish them nothing but the best
individually too and together do you
feel like
you know if you had told shane earlier
in the in the in the show or in the in
the process that he was your number one
do you think that you guys would have
gotten engaged and gotten married i
don't know if it would have worked i i
don't know shane as deep as natalie
knows shane seeing things unfold um
i don't even know if me and shane would
have made it on a romantic level could
have been more on our friendship that
makes sense since the first few episodes
the first drop of episodes aired people
were comparing you to jessica from the
first season how did you feel about that
comparison first and foremost i think
it's so sad how
people are calling me like the jessica
like villainizing jessica i guess until
you experience reality television you
will never know what i said i go i will
never judge another reality person ever
again
um
i definitely think also where our
situations were two complete different
situations and i think maybe the
comparison is is the villain like she
was villainized by the public and i'm
definitely being villainized by the
public is there anything else about this
experience that you feel like you want
people to know i guess i would want the
public to know that what was portrayed
is not who i am i am not a homewrecker i
feel that people should just understand
and take it in that this is reality
television me and the cast i feel like
we're definitely we're all at a healing
point and so
the world is so angry but they need to
understand that like we are all
kind of at a healing point and then
again people
who know me they're not even questioning
me so it's been honestly i've had even
more love than hate
[Music]